Support for Think Fast Talk Smart comes
from Stanford Continuing Studies.
Stanford Continuing Studies offers
over 150 online classes on a wide
range of topics from art history to AI,
wellness to writing,
as well as courses on business and
communication.
Fall registration opens August 16th and
is open to all adult learners everywhere.
Most classes start the week
of September 20th.
Learn more at
continuingstudies.stanford.edu.
[MUSIC]
>> Imagine what it would be like to be at
your best every time you communicated,
alert, focused, engaged,
and with minimal fear.
Today, using research from neuroscience,
we'll explore how you can hack your
communication to maximize your impact.
I'm Matt Abrahams, and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast.
I am really looking forward to speaking
with Andrew Huberman, who is a professor
in the neurobiology department at
Stanford University School of Medicine.
Andrew's research focuses on understanding
the brain mechanisms controlling anxiety,
cognition and performance under stress.
Additionally, Andrew works diligently to
bring neuroscience research to the public,
through his teaching, his videos and
his Huberman lab podcast which
needs to be in everyone's playlist.
Thanks for being here, Andrew,
should we get started?
>> Delighted to be here.
>> Like me, I know you're
fascinated by fear and its impact.
As we all know, communicating in front
of others in high stakes situations can
certainly involve fear.
From a neurologic point of view,
what's going on.
What happens to our voice, our speech and
our hand movements when we get nervous?
>> So when we get nervous, we are entering
a state which is perfectly natural but
reflects one station along what's
called the autonomic continuum.
And really the autonomic
continuum can be conceptualized as
a continuum between states
of very high alertness,
think maximum excitement or
fear all the way down to deep sleep.
So our states of mind and
body are not discrete entities,
they are along this continuum,
this autonomic continuum.
So when we are excited or we are nervous,
we have a number of physiological
responses that are purely autonomic,
meaning they're purely automatic.
The most important thing to
realize is that it is a continuum.
It has some features that
are autonomic meaning automatic.
And that there's no difference between
the physiological response to something
that you're excited about,
and something that you're nervous about or
that you're dreading.
And so there's an additional component
there that we need to consider.
But the most important thing above all,
and
I guess if people are going to take away
anything from our conversation today,
it's that despite these responses being
automatic, there are direct control
points through which we can control
the autonomic nervous system.
Meaning that we can dial down
the level of alertness, or
increase the level of calmness.
Those actually turn out to
be two different things.
So while it's called the autonomic nervous
system and the autonomic continuum,
it's a bit of a misnomer.
Because there are two specific levers or
entry points that we all have from
birth that require essentially no
learning, you have to know what they are.
But that will allow people to
control voice, level of alertness,
level of shaking in their hands.
So it's a quite remarkable system in
that it has this asymmetry, autonomic on
the one hand but with very powerful
entry points for control on the other.
>> I want to get back to the notion
that you brought up about
how we experience the physiological
arousal that we get.
You said, in some cases,
it's due to anxiety and fear.
In other cases, it's due to excitement.
Part of that, I think, has to do with
how we label what we're experiencing.
And I know that there's some
research from my academic field,
that says one way to help manage anxiety
is just to work on how you perceive
the physiological symptoms
that you're having.
So, if you say, hey, even though my heart
rate is going up, I'm getting a little
sweaty and shaky, it's because I'm excited
to share the information I'm sharing,
versus my goodness, everybody is
looking at me and I'm feeling nervous.
So part of it, I think,
has to do with how we frame the situation.
Does that ring true?
>> Absolutely, when we are in a state of
alertness, whether because of excitement
or fear, the sympathetic division of the
autonomic nervous system, let's just call
it the alertness system, deploys a hormone
from our adrenal glands, adrenaline.
And it deploys the equivalent chemical in
the brain where it's called epinephrine.
It's actually the same
chemically identical structure,
but called two different things
because neuroscientists and
physiologists like to
make things complicated.
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> Not simple, but
the role of adrenaline slash epinephrine
is to create agitation in the body and
to create focus in the mind.
And this is an important
concept because that agitation
makes it harder to be still,
which is sort of a duh, right?
That's the definition of agitation.
But it was designed to physically move us,
so
that we would be biased toward ambulation.
We're biased toward shifting
from one position to a new one.
And so one of the toughest things for
many people is to tolerate that level of
adrenaline or
alertness when they have to be still.
The simplest example I can give of this
that I think most people will be familiar
with is, in the days where
we congregated in person,
there's this traditional practice
of going around the room and
introducing yourself, and
saying something about what you do.
And most people actually find
that to be very stressful,
especially toward the end of the line.
Now why would that be, right?
Most people know their name and
can say their name.
Most people know what they do and
can say that, it's anything but
a high stress circumstance.
And occasionally, there's some
social pressure where if someone's
very funny before us or they say
something in a particularly nice way,
then we feel some additional
pressure to do that as well.
But it really has more to do with the fact
that when we're in a room listening
to somebody,
we're comfortable with the fact that we're
not going to speak or walk or do much.
And we can just sit there and
write or listen or text or
whatever it is we have to do.
As we are called on to say something,
the reason it's easier
to do early in the line is because we
are holding on to a reverberatory circuit.
There are circuits in our brain that
anticipate action and prepare us for
action.
And the longer we keep that in check,
the more challenging it becomes.
When we are trying to withhold action,
but we're preparing for
action, there's a lot of reverberatory,
excuse me, activity in our nervous
system and it feels like stres.
Getting ready to go up
to the podium is tough.
When we get up to the podium,
many people, including myself,
find that if we rock back and
forth a little bit, or
we can engage some movement in our body,
suddenly we start to relax.
And that's because adrenaline slash
epinephrine was designed to move us.
And it wasn't designed to move us in
response to incoming large predators,
it was, but
that's not its primary function.
Its primary function was to move us
from whatever position we're in to a new
position, sometimes towards things,
sometimes away from things, depending on
whether or not we want the experience or
we want to avoid the experience.
But the actual inner experience,
what we call interoception,
our perception of our internal
landscape is identical For
something that we want to approach
versus we want to move away from,
absolutely identical below that
from the neck down that is.
>> Really interesting.
So, if you can reframe the physiological
response, you can see it very differently.
And I find fascinating that when
we see somebody who is nervous.
Moving one way versus the other way,
as an audience member,
we have very different perception.
So if somebody steps up on a stage, and
then takes a step back as
they're starting to speak,
it looks like they're retreating,
and therefore maybe nervous or shy.
But if somebody actually steps forward, we
have a perception that they're confident
and stepping into
the challenging situation.
So, it's not only what we perceive it's
how the audience perceives it as well.
>> Absolutely.
It's might be useful for people to think
about the fact that there's only three
responses we can have to any circumstance.
One is to stay still, one is to move
forward, or one is to move back.
Back in 2018, a graduate student
in the neurosciences program,
who did her thesis with me Lindsay Silay.
And I published a paper
in the Journal Nature,
Lindsay discovered a brain circuit that
controls the movement toward threats.
Now, this isn't the kind of
movement that will get you killed.
This is the kind of movement toward in
an intelligent way, in an adaptive way,
towards something that, in this case
an animal or a person wants to do, but
feels a tremendous amount of autonomic
arousal of stress and nervousness about.
And the take home message
is the following,
forward movement under conditions of
anxiety or high levels of alertness,
aka stress, triggers the activation
of a circuit deep in the brain
that releases the neurochemical dopamine.
Dopamine, of course,
is a molecule that is most commonly
associated with a sensation of reward.
And it is released when we achieve
something that we want to achieve.
But the other very interesting
function of dopamine, is to increase
the probability that we will move toward
similar types of goals in the future.
So, dopamine is not just
the molecule reward,
it's the molecule of motivation and drive.
And so, Lindsay's results have
a number of different implications.
But I think if people can just
conceptualize that the anxiety or
stress response is the same as the
excitement response, they feel different
because of some top down perception or
verbiage that we introduced to it.
But they're actually
identical physiologically and
that forward movement provided it's
adaptive toward a goal, triggers
the activation of chemicals in the brain
and body that will make the subsequent
pursuit of those same or similar goals
more likely and more pleasurable.
>> That's really cool.
So learning to take the stage and
step forward,
leaning in when your virtual can help.
And I believe in some of
the work of yours that I read,
you don't actually have
to even physically move.
If you simulate movement with your eyes,
you can have a similar effect, and
I'd like for you to talk about that.
>> Back in the early 80s,
someone actually in Palo Alto,
a woman by the name of Francine Shapiro
is a psychologist developed a technique,
it was actually developed for
trauma treatment.
She was a psychologist, did some work at
Stanford, but also at a nearby clinic.
And essentially, she had found
that taking walks was helpful for
her anxiety and stress.
Something that everyone now
I think says okay, dab, but
we always thought that it was
because of movement in the body.
But she wanted to import some of that
self-induced relaxation to her clinic.
And she was clever enough to create
this thing that they call EMDR,
Eye Movement Desensitization Reprocessing,
which simply involves moving
the eyes from side to side.
It looks a little goofy,
if you see someone do it.
But moving the eyes from side to side,
not up or down, but
side to side eye movement
actually triggers, we now know,
suppression of the amygdala,
this fear center in the brain.
And for years, people would ask me about
EMDR, because I'm a vision scientist and
I work on stress.
And I thought it was totally kooky and
crazy, and I didn't believe any of it.
And my response was, in my mind anyway
was sort of, okay, take your EMDR and
your magic carpet and-
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> And head down to Big Sur and let's
talk later, if you want to talk science.
But I was really quite wrong, because
a couple of years ago, there were no fewer
than five papers published in very
high-quality journals including, Nature.
In mice, non-human primates, and
human showing that these lateralized eye
movements lead to suppression of
this fear center in the brain.
So it's a quite long lasting effect.
I should just mention, if people
are going to use it to deal with actual
trauma, that shouldn't be done
with a real trauma threat.
>> Sure, right.
>> It works best for specific
circumstances like public speaking.
It's not great for sort of reducing your
stress about your entire childhood, or
your entire-
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> Divorce, or your entire 2020.
It's best geared toward specific
circumstances, but here's how it works.
You move your eyes from side to side for
about 30 seconds,
which is actually quite a long time.
You don't do this during the event.
>> Right.
>> But that creates a state of reduced
alertness, aka stress, not so
much you fall asleep in your system.
And then you're able to better
approach things with more ease and
with less alertness.
>> I've heard you mentioned
on your podcast that there
are two approaches to dressing stress,
can you share those with us?
>> The two approaches are you can
either reduce your stress in real time,
things like this eye movements right
before you go into a stressful event,
like up on stage, or hard conversation, or
even if you're just experiencing anxiety.
There's a breathing tool I'll share
with you in a moment that's grounded
deeply in physiology as well.
Or you can raise your stress threshold,
so things like ice baths,
running up steep mountains,
exposure therapy.
Those are actually designed to increase
your cognitive tolerance for high levels
of agitation in your body, increasing
the probability that you will stay still,
not say the wrong thing, not strike
anyone, not lose your cool, right?
>> Right.
>> So, it's sort of learning to be calm in
storm or what is sometimes referred to as
being comfortable being uncomfortable.
That is a distinctly
different set of practices.
Then things like the eye movement that
I described, or the second thing,
which is a real time tool for calming
oneself that My Laboratory is working
closely on with David Pigott's Laboratory
on the department of psychiatry.
Which is we ask the question,
what breathing approach is the best
to calm oneself in real time?
Because meditation is wonderful, TM is
wonderful, if you're of drinking age and
you can tolerate it without going into
excess, a nice glass of wine is also
another way to activate the-
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> So is a massage, so
is a dip in the hot tub or a sauna.
>> Sounds like you're
describing a nice date.
[LAUGH]
>> Right, yeah, exactly.
And remember it's called the rest and
digest system for a reason,
one of the most powerful ways to shift
your autonomic nervous system to one of
more calmness is to fill
your gut with food.
That then the distention of your gut
sends signals through the vagus nerve to
a little clap set of neurons, right behind
your ear called the nodose ganglia,
which projects into your brain,
gives you a little bit of a dopamine hit.
This is well established,
as well as activating areas of the brain
that are involved in calming you down.
And so, there are a lot of ways to control
the autonomic nervous system slowly and
indirectly, massage, hot tub,
big meal, et cetera.
We're talking about
real time control fast.
So, the best way that we know, and
this is work that's still in progress,
is to use what are called
physiological sighs.
So, these were discovered back in the 30s.
Turns out that when you are stressed,
you are breathing less deeply.
The most common advice is
to take a deep breath.
>> Right.
>> It turns out that's
exactly the wrong advice.
>> No.
>> Exhale emphasized breathing leads to
much more rapid activation of the calming
arm of the nervous system.
And it turns out, you don't just want to
exhale, you want to do a double inhale.
So inhale twice through the nose.
So inhale through the nose,
and then before you exhale,
sneak in a little bit more air,
and then do a long exhale.
And you do this just one to three times.
So it's inhale, inhale again, even if
you just sneak the tiniest bit of air.
Ideally, the inhales are done through the
nose, and then exhale through the mouth.
Now, why does this work?
Turns out that your lungs are not
just two big bags of air.
They are billions of little tiny sacs
called the alveoli of the lungs.
>> Right.
>> Those little sacs are contiguous,
more or less, with the vasculature,
with the blood supply.
So when you exhale, you offload carbon
dioxide, and a lot of the stress response
is due to elevated carbon
dioxide in the bloodstream.
If you've ever been to a kid's party, and
you're asked to blow up a balloon and
you blow on the balloon.
Sometimes it inflates right away, but
if it doesn't, you give two
hard pushes with air, one, two.
And the same thing happens
with the alveoli of the lungs.
As we get stressed,
they start to collapse, they flatten out.
And to reinflate them,
the double inhale brings maximal air
into the alveoli of your lungs, and
then you offload the maximum amount
of carbon dioxide when you exhale.
So this is very simple, very fast.
You can actually do it
during exercise as well.
So if you ever find that your heart is
pounding and you want to calm down,
first thing is exhale.
Then maybe try the double inhale,
and then exhale will follow.
Usually, at least what
we find in our studies,
is that within just one to three of those
cycles, meaning within about five seconds,
autonomic nervous system starts
to shift more towards calmness.
And then if you like you can start
using your eye movements or whatever,
cognitive reframing.
But one of the things that I
think will resonate with people,
and I hope it does, is that it is very
hard to control the mind with the mind.
When you're stepping up to the podium and
you are nervous,
you can say, yeah, that nervousness
is actually excitement and
I must be really agitated because
I really want to do this.
But in that moment of stress,
it's very hard to control what's going on.
So under conditions where your
mind is not where you want it,
use the body to control the mind.
>> So you've just shared techniques for
what we can do when we're
directly experiencing anxiety.
What can we do to prepare for
anxiety in advance?
>> The other thing to do is the stuff
that you do away from the podium,
away from the big event or
the hard conversation.
And that involves deliberately taking
yourself into states of heightened
alertness.
As my colleague
David Spiegel likes to say,
it's not just about the state you find
yourself in, it's how you got there, and
whether or
not you had anything to do with it.
And what he's really saying is that when
you drive your nervous system into a state
of high alertness and
you learn to be calm there.
You achieve a certain kind of superpower
such that when real life puts you into
those states without any warning and
very fast, it's like driving in fog.
The first time you do it,
it's scary as heck.
The fifth time to do it,
it's still scary, but
you've been there before, and
so you're now a good driver.
So the way you do this can be
of different practices, but
one of the best ones
is a very cold shower.
And trying to stay calm for one to
three minutes in a very cold shower.
>> Wow.
>> Not something that I like,
it's not very pleasant.
And there you use a protocol of
breathing that involves taking
25 to 30 deep inhales, for
reasons that now should be obvious,
increase your heart rate,
and then big exhale.
[SOUND]
>> Hyperventilating like.
>> You hyperventilate.
And by the 25th one,
you will be very stressed.
Now I want to say that if people are panic
attack prone or anxiety attack prone,
I do not recommend this,
very uncomfortable.
But then what you do at the end of that
25 breaths is you offload all your air,
you empty your lungs.
[SOUND] And then you sit for
about 15 to, some people can go longer,
60 seconds or so, lungs empty.
And you try and
feel peaceful with that heightened
level of adrenaline in your body.
Now, never do this near water, I want to
be really clear because there is this
thing called shallow water, but
don't even do it in a puddle,
because I don't want anyone
injuring themselves or worse.
But if you repeat that for two or
three cycles, what you will find,
it's pretty remarkable.
There's some nuance to these practices,
but they all kind of start and
end with vision or breathing.
>> Right, and I love how you make
them simple for us to understand.
So they're the things we
can do in the moment, or
right before the moment of the anxiety.
And then they're things we can do to, in
essence, desensitize ourselves in advance.
Now, we are all communicating in
this virtual world these days.
Is there anything from your experience
of how eyes work that would indicate
what we should do?
For example, people often say,
you need to look at the camera so
it looks like you're looking at
the person on the other end.
Any insight you have about this
virtual communication we all do?
>> Okay, well, first of all,
it's a very unnatural time,
most of all because we are not used to
seeing a little picture of ourselves
moving while we look at other people.
Everyone's carrying a little mirror
around on their shoulder for
us now in this world.
So turn that off, or
get it out of the way,
because it will interfere with your
presence to the conversation and
other people's perception
of how present you are.
The other thing that's
really important is,
there's a lot of research on gaze and
eye contact, and frequency of blinking.
The most powerful way to connect
with somebody through Zoom or
just in person, is actually not to
stare directly at them the whole time.
Is a combination of direct gaze,
averting gaze, and closing one's eyes.
A real conversation involves moments
whereyoue're looking away trying to,
like I'm doing right now,
I'm trying grab a concept and
say it in a way that makes sense.
But then also where we re-engage.
And so a conversation is actually
a process of looking directly at the other
person and then breaking gaze and
then coming back again.
The other thing that works quite well if
people are experiencing eye fatigue from
looking at screens up close, and there's
a whole other conversation, one thing that
works well is to see someone's
face at the beginning, say hello.
Because faces are a powerful,
collects a lot of context for the brain.
>> Sure.
>> Saying hello, but
then going into pure audio, and then going
back to visual before you part ways.
That may actually be a more effective form
of Zoom communication than pretending
we're all in the same room and trying to
stare at one another the entire time and
sometimes see that
reflection of ourselves.
>> Right, and that's advice that
others on this podcast have given,
that you don't have to show
your video the whole time.
So before we end, Andrew, I'd like to
ask you the same three questions I ask
everybody who joins me on this podcast.
Are you up for that?
>> Definitely.
>> If you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever received,
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would that be?
>> Speak to inform, and
teach, not impress.
>> I like that.
So it's about getting
the information across.
And you are certainly a master at that.
And I encourage everybody To search
out some of the work you've done,
your podcast is fantastic because
you do such a nice job of something
we talked about on an earlier podcast, how
to make complex information accessible.
You do a great job of that.
You certainly don't dumb it down, but
you make it accessible as you've done for
us today.
Lemme ask question number two, who is
a communication that you admire and why?
>> There two forms of communication
that really appealed to me and
the they will seem at
odds with one another.
I love poetry because great poetry doesn't
really make sense at a cognitive level.
It gets to a kind of what probably is
some sort of deeper, universal meaning.
It probably is tapping into
brain circuits that are more on
a emotional level or
that reside in the brain body connection.
I really believe that so that speaks
to some sort of quote unquote truth.
So I love poetry and
I'm a big Wendell Berry fan.
I'm also a big Joe Strummer fan, most
famous for being the singer the clash for
the things he said Not
while he was on stage.
So Joe Strummer is brilliant in
terms of his offstage speech, for
people to check out some of the things
that Joe said later in his life
were really remarkable insights
into human beings and humanity.
There's some real core truth there.
And in the world of science
Claude Despawn is a Biology
professor at NYU who
studies insect vision.
And the only word that I can use to
describe what it is to hear one of
Claude's lecture, whether or
not you're familiar with Biology or
not is pure enchantment.
He transports you into a world
where frankly I don't really care
about dragonfly vision
on a regular basis but
when I listen to Claude speak I think
about human vision I think about love.
He talks about the love spots
of the dragon fly eyes thats for
pursuing meats and food and
it's just remarkable.
And anyone that can do
that is incredible but
Claude is the world
heavyweight champion of
making Biology fascinating and delightful.
>> Well, I'm going to check
his lectures out for sure.
Last question for you.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> Passion,
the speaker has to love the topic.
In organizational logic,
there has to be a structure
to the information.
It just can't be bullet points and
beginning middle end kind of thing.
And clarity.
If people walk away understanding
more than they did at the beginning,
then you won, get back to the the most
important thing to do is to
teach your audience educate them.
>> Passion, structure, and clarity, PSC.
We're going to add that as another acronym
to your list of many acronyms I've heard
you talk about.
Andrew, it was fantastic to have you here.
I'm taking a deep breath to calm myself
down from all the exciting information
that you shared, thank you so much.
It is my true hope that all of us
listening in can apply some of these tools
and hacks to optimize our communication,
thank you.
>> Thanks so much for having me.
[MUSIC]
>> Thank you for
listening to Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
To learn more, go to gsb.stanford.edu,
please download other episodes
wherever you find your podcasts.
[MUSIC]